think of a word or a topic or a phrase
that you like rap about but there's like
a big responsibility you guys don't
realize people always you know think
that it's fun to shout like titties
baseball and you can be
more difficult
what was that
heroin you said heroine
found 1980s
I love the old school drugs heroine I
actually felt very flatter the other day
I was working on Bleaker Street and I
know that this guy the guy was there
just says everyone but I walked past him
he was like cool cool cool he's looked
at me and just said to me and I felt
very like oh thank you
[Music]
so okay so heroin is a great first topic
actually there's not many rap songs
about heroin right you know there's a
great they read track about it we loved
about the underground but heroin rare in
rap songs so but for the rest of you
just know that you can be really
difficult you can don't say anything
that I've mentioned don't mention the
Queen Don't British people don't say
anything weird and British because like
I said the Americans don't understand
that poetry and the best suggestion ever
was a German man who said a day into
life
of an Aztec high priest
foreign
was there a suggestion or an order was
there a request
you're on you won't sound the same table
as you're a dealer
okay well that came from this section I
guess so let's I want to make it fair so
we'll come to this section we'll get
four more suggestions I feel so five is
pretty decent so people over here what
would you like to rap about never walk
alone so I said don't suggest Niche
British things see no one else
knows it is the anthem of Liverpool
Football Club
um exactly you don't give a [ __ ] about
that I will I will let you I'll let you
take a shot at another thing something
that Americans will understand
brick you looked at the wall
[Applause]
unless you're gonna come to me now and
go no I'm talking about the early 2000s
movie about rhianne Johnson but I don't
think you when Joseph Gordon-Levitt
talks too fast right brick okay so
heroin and brick nice and what did you
say what did you say pardon theater Club
theater Club yes were you in theater
Club no but it seems like
it'll be funny look at you mocking all
the little nerds who did that fit
do they okay cool I mean I'm British and
my parents have money but they
lie we grow Manchester but I don't sound
like it because I wanted to be
employable
theater Club Aaron so theater Club is
like like is there like Glee Club but
just with acting like summer camp summer
camp yeah
I love you that's a brilliant suggestion
so just so you know we've only got one
suggestion left so it has to be better
than all these put together and so far
I'm pretty pleased with cast iron
skillet heroin theater Club brick
s
what did you say vegetarian vegetarians
are you mocking let me figure out your
perspective on them are you a meat eater
or a vegan
well yeah because either you're punching
up or punch him down
judging by that you're a meat eater
right because a vegan would be like it
does matter very much
I'm grateful that you gave me this
moment to proselytize
the word proselytize has never been set
on this stage
vegetarians brick heroin theater club
and uh cast iron skillet this is a
freestyle on all those things I'm so
glad to be here with one of the talent
fans and all of the planet world
so uh do you want to drop a beat and
we'll we'll wrap up whatever you've come
up with
oh
okay
[Music]
I love Red's face when he plays piano
it's my favorite thing in the world
right
so uh which one do you want us to start
with
brick
it's How We Do It kicker outsole sick
let me flow like this shouting out Chris
brick please it's right there I'm in
fraud I had my eyes fixed and I saw that
wall light what am I gonna pick b-r-i-c
at the little pig coming ever so easy
they're amazing like wow without no
bricks we would have no house Heaven
Sent much better than cement I ought to
play Down to the mortar it went you've
gotta get the little trout put it up use
a hard carry them round I'm a bricklayer
I'm a guy with the hot board moving all
around yeah so I really thank God walk
around with my brick there in transport
bricks of cocaine and heroin where from
South America
14 that's the purest one but heroin
shoot that thing into my arms I felt
like I removed my belt put it outside I
tighten it myself and then I sink in the
floor yes I'm dropping if you've seen
that scene in Trainspotting a dead baby
crawling on the ceiling had heroin once
had that feeling that I was outside oh
my gosh it feels like I Wanna Be sit on
that horse on that horse heroin in my
arm if you don't do it then the third
time's the charm put it in give your
veins a rub and then go and do some of
the queens of theater Club you can win
Shakespeare read Marlo read some Becca
and everyone hangs low like you're
incredible with your monologue I'm doing
this with the heroin in my body I feel
very slim like heroin sheet do my day a
club they applaud when I speak I'm on
stage everybody not movies theater why
cause my parents are bougie you've got a
lot of cash got a lot of money into
theater Club one day I'll be funny you
didn't do the
maybe that's the thing I could switch
into infiltrated from the inside once
you're in there all the kids are quite
snides they really mean that there are
kids on stage like oh you're not good
step away from the page of the script
they would even spit on you it's kind of
mean that they picked this mean to do
the next thing I'm in the kitchen I'll
kill it fry it up cook it with the cast
iron skillet the most important thing
I'll say it today you don't need to make
sure that it's late it's the top reason
make sure that it's seasoned put it on
for five minutes with the heating if
start burning does the job and Asian
people you'd call it a Whopper cast iron
skillet like it's in the Hamptons
Martha's Vineyard this [ __ ] Champion
I can cook it up on the grill put a
little bit of steak on there not chilled
make sure that it's room temperature
otherwise it's burnt if you're all chefs
then your [ __ ] learn I'll be
spitting
[ __ ] take care cast iron skillet
never use the washing up Liquid really
cooking I'm addicted to this you can
scrub it not with the wire wall get it
off then you know you get an earful from
any head chef like we we get my cast
iron skillet coming easy now the last
one remind me had too many drinks we had
a fifth one as well and I think of
course how could we even forget I talked
about the steak make the meat eaters wet
but the vegetarians and the vegans to
say we don't like him for one weird
reason animal products that's really
mean you could eat lima beans for
protein maybe get some lentils maybe get
some tofu vegetarians who the [ __ ] shows
you you think you're really cool eating
all the plants but actually even the
vegetarians glance liquor scans although
sanctimonious Pricks all the vegans out
there they've been picking up their lips
like I can't believe he wouldn't get my
vote he should only eat milk made from
almond or
do you find you are employed and let me
say this it makes no sense plant
alternative milk to an extra 25 cents
why the [ __ ] would I pay for it take it
off me I want the cow milk in my coffee
vegetarians yeah [ __ ] believe if you
like plants so much you should leave
that's a plant pot back there can't be
beef vegetarians I don't like sheep or
meat any cow there we go it's how we
talk yeah bacon bacon eating that pork
foreign